simplifica la expresión 18 x a la cuarta
menos 3x cuadrada más 6 x 4 / 6 x es una
división de un polinomio entre un mono
mió hay varias formas de pensar en esta
división y bueno cualquiera de estas nos
va a llevar a la siguiente expresión nos
va a llevar a que tenemos que hacer la
división de cada uno de los monos entre
6 hechos o sea 18 x a la cuarta dividido
entre 6 x menos 3 x al cuadrado dividido
entre 6 x más 6 x dividido entre 6 x
menos 4 dividido entre 6 x va como te
decía hay muchas formas de pensar en
cómo se puede llegar a esta expresión no
sé o sea una forma más o menos directa
es pensar que estamos descomponiendo
algo del estilo más bmc entre d / d como
la división a entre d
+ la b / de más la c / de ba
y bueno si quieres explicaciones un poco
más sensatas pues pues básicamente
podemos pensar que estamos distribuyendo
esta división en cada uno de los de los
humanos podemos pensar en una ley
distributiva de la división o bueno
siendo todavía más formales podemos
pensar esta misma expresión como 1 entre
6 x 1 entre 6 x x 18 x a la cuarta menos
3 x al cuadrado más 6 x menos 4 y
entonces ahora si simplemente estamos
usando la ley distributiva de la
multiplicación para llegar a esta
expresión bueno en fin todas estas
formas de pensarlo son equivalentes y
son bastante lógicas va la cosa es que
ahora tenemos un montón de mono mios
divididos entre 6x y queremos ver que
nos da bueno para esto simplemente vamos
a hacer división de números y leyes de
los exponentes déjame empezar con este
color azul hito entonces vamos con este
primer término con este primer término
entonces cuánto nos quedaría 18 entre 6
estrés entonces ahí queda un 33 luego
exista la cuarta entre x a la no nos
dicen cuánto pero cuando no nos dicen es
que aquí hay un 1
entonces x a la cuarta entre quizá la 1
para hacer esta división podemos usar
leyes de los exponentes tenemos que
restar los exponentes 4 - 1 estrés nos
quedaría x a la 41 que es x al cubo
entonces nos queda 3x al cubo ese es el
primer término luego vamos con este de
acá tenemos que sumar menos 3 en 36
déjame ponerle que es una resta entonces
menos 3 entre 6 es un medio un medio y
luego vamos con la equis con las
potencias de x aquí tenemos x al
cuadrado y aquí x a la 12 menos uno es
uno entonces nos queda x a la 1 entonces
aquí podría ponerle x a la 1
no voy a ponerlo pero bueno ahorita que
simplificamos se lo quitamos van porque
quizá la 1 es simplemente
ok vamos con este término de acá este
término de acá se ve se ve luego luego
que es que es igual a 1 verdad 6x entre
6 x es igual a 1
pero vamos a hacerlo con calma 6 en 36
es uno en efecto y luego hay que
multiplicar por equis entre equis que
también es uno bueno a menos que sea
cero hay que tener cuidado estamos
pensando que este no es cero verdad si
dividimos entre cero pasan cosas raras
pero pensando que x no es cero podemos
pensar esta x como x a la 1 esta x como
x a la 1 y aplicando las leyes de los
exponentes nos quedaba x a la 11 que se
fija la 0 que vaya vuelve a ser uno
siempre es uno va entonces aquí tenemos
un 1 ahorita lo ponemos como un 1 y
finalmente déjame ir a este término al
menos 4 entre 6 x menos 4 entre 6 es
menos dos tercios menos dos tercios y
pues a ver cuánto nos queda aquí pues
aquí tenemos que dividir entre x aquí
está entre 1 arriba no tenemos x pero
podemos pensar que hay una equis a la 0
entonces si lo pensamos así este x a la
0 que es un 1 no afecta en nada y
entonces podemos pensar que nos queda x
0 - 1 o sea x a la menos uno vaya
estamos dividiendo entre x
si entonces sería menos 12
3x este dividir entre x es lo mismo que
x a la menos 1 muy bien nada raro por
ahí bueno ya que tenemos estos numeritos
vamos a escribirla así la expresión un
poco más bonita para que ya no tenga
exponentes raros y así entonces la
reescribimos pues con un color un nuevo
con rosa entonces nos quedaría 3x al
cubo pues es 3x al cubo 3 x al cubo
menos un medio de x un medio de x ya no
le pongo este exponente más 1
+ 1 - 2 / 3x va a menos 2 / 3x y con
esto ya está simplificada bueno osea
podrías argumentar que a lo mejor no
quiere es que haya x en el denominador
entonces tendríamos que poner este
término como menos 2 entre 3 x a la
menos 1 bueno ya depende cuál es tu
favorito este es éste sino quieres x en
el denominador y este es si no quieres
exponentes negativos